and now I'd like to read you one of my
favorite books the giving tree by shel
silverstein once there was a tree and
she loved a little boy and every day the
boy would come and he would gather her
leaves and make them into crowns and
play king of the forest he would climb
up her trunk and swing from her branches
and eat apples and they would play
hide-and-go-seek and when he was tired
he would sleep in her shade and the boy
loved the tree very much and the tree
was happy but time went by and the boy
grew older and the tree was often alone
then one day the boy came to the tree
and the tree said come boy come and
climb up my trunk and swing from my
branches and eat apples and play in my
shade and be happy I'm too big to climb
and play said the boy I want to buy
things and have fun I want some money
can you give me some money I'm sorry
said the tree but I have no money I have
only leaves and apples take my apples
boy and sell them in the city then
you'll have money and you'll be happy
and so the boy climbed up the tree and
gathered her apples and carried them
away and the tree was happy but the boy
stayed away for a long time and the tree
was sad and then one day the boy came
back and the tree shook with joy and she
said come boy climb up my trunk and
swing from my branches and be happy I'm
too busy to climb trees at the boy I
want a house to keep me warm he said I
want a wife and I want children
and so I need a house can you give me a
house I have no house at the tree but
you may cut off my branches and build
the house then you will be happy and so
the boy cut off her branches and carried
them away to build his house and the
tree was happy but the boy stayed away
for a long time and when he came back
the tree was so happy she could hardly
speak come boy she whispered come and
play I'm too old and sad to play said
the boy I want a boat that will take me
far away from here can you give me a
boat cut down my trunk and make a boat
set the tree then you can sail away and
be happy and so the boy cut down her
trunk and made a boat and sailed away
and the tree was happy but not really
and after a long time the boy came back
again I'm sorry boy said the tree but I
have nothing left to give you my apples
are gone my teeth are too weak for Apple
said the boy my branches are gone said
the tree you cannot swing on them I'm
too old to swing on branches said the
boy my trunk is gone said the tree you
cannot climb I'm too tired to climb said
the boy I'm sorry sighed the tree I wish
that I could give you something but I
have nothing left I'm just an old stump
I'm sorry I don't need very much now
said the boy just a quiet place to sit
and rest I'm very tired well said the
tree straightening herself up as much as
she could well an old stump is good for
sitting and resting come boy sit down
and rest and the boy did and the tree
was happy
the end